outspoken a mí me gusta a mí esto de
hablar siempre los en la lengua que es
normalmente lo que suelo hacer
habitualmente
pero claro cuando a una le dicen vas a
tener 18 minutos para hablar sin pelos
en la lengua por cierto no tengo aquí el
tiempo con lo cual podemos estar aquí
hasta la nochevieja yo que vosotros me
lo pondría acaso estas gracias no
debería haberlo pedido
bueno la cuestión es que yo estoy segura
de que estéis pensando bueno esta chica
monologuista cómica comunicadora verdad
seguro que ha sido siempre muy segura en
sí misma que ha hablado siempre sin
pelos en la lengua que ha hablado muy
claro y que ha sido siempre así no
cuando me propusieron venir a ted es una
de las cosas que pensé fue porque no les
hablo de dónde vengo porque la mayoría
de vosotros habéis visto o un habéis
visto por tele me habéis visto en algún
espectáculo de monólogo o en alguna cosa
cómica pero nunca sabéis de dónde
procede todo esto bien me cliente
barcelona madrid y albacete
mis familias de la sierra de alcaraz yo
vengo de allí y prácticamente no hable
hasta la adolescencia
no hablaba porque no hablaba había dos
cuestiones una observaba y callaba y dos
digamos que mi familia no era una
familia fácil mi papá era un señor muy
difícil había sido militar había sido un
gris después pasó a ser funcionario del
estado habitualmente llevaba porra y era
un señor muy poco divertido este hombre
estuvo hasta los 11 12 años viendo en mi
casa con mi madre mi hermano pequeñito
con el cual me llevo 8 años y yo misma
la vida fue un infierno hasta el punto
de que yo ya os digo no hablaba no
hablaba en casa no prácticamente en el
colegio el psicólogo y el médico
llamaron a mi madre para decirle la niña
es rara
apenas habla y los dibujos son negros
grises y marrones no hay colores en sus
dibujos
mi madre tomo con muy buen criterio una
opción muy buena y fue regalarme colores
libros para leer cuentos para leer y
dejarme que escribiese lo que yo
quisiese y que pintase lo que yo
quisiese eso me permitió hacerme un
mundo paralelo
donde cada vez que mi padre entraba por
casa por la puerta y empezaba a temblar
yo podía dibujar
o escribir e irme allí por eso no
hablaba
pasé por colegios de monjas tengo decir
las dos cosas colegios de monjas
estupendos de misioneras y colegios de
monjas donde decías una palabra y te
daban con la regla en la cabeza
directamente casi casi que un
zapatillazo pero pasaba nada estas cosas
hoy en día son mal vistas pero entonces
era lo normal y lo común porque yo soy
muy mayor aunque no lo parezca
he de deciros que bueno ya por fin
gracias a dios dios mío
dios mis padres se separan se divorcian
mi padre se va para allá se pierde de
vista nos abandona se larga nos deja sin
nada la pensión alimenticia no la pasa
25 años de litigio entre a mi madre y mi
padre hasta hasta casi casi casi como
soy ahora que tengo 22 años
todo muy complicado pero por fin mi
madre decide venirse albacete y fijaros
qué curioso albacete fue mi salvación
extraño porque yo venía ya os digo de
barcelona y madrid yo venía desde los
tres años aunque no hablaba me llevaban
a clases de teatro a mi madre intentaba
por todos los medios que yo
salir hacia afuera y yo no lo conseguía
pero mi madre me lleva a clases de
teatro me va a clases dibujo me lleva
hasta clases de puzzle os imagináis lo
que es hacer clases de puzzle saca
halladay
os lo juro clases extraescolares raras
que hacían en cataluña
la cuestión es que mi madre ya llegamos
albacete y dice bueno a ver si por dios
esta niña empieza y si albacete me crea
un sitio donde prácticamente no había
clases de teatro entonces no había no
había apenas había muy poquito arte
había muy poquitas cosas y yo un poco a
poco empezó a decir bueno porque no lo
que yo llevo años aprendiendo en
barcelona y en madrid empiezo a
enseñarlo a mis amigos a mis amigas de
la gente que me rodea empiezo a entrar
en asociaciones fundó y soy parte de la
organización de la asociación de jóvenes
artistas de castilla-la mancha' y
empiezo de repente a darme cuenta de que
de ser un gusano aterrorizado y callado
pasa a ser este pedazo de mariposón
esas cosas es así
el señor
[Aplausos]
y ahí fue cuando yo empecé a hacer
teatro el teatro fue mi salvación
realmente el teatro la gente salir bueno
tener esta libertad que nunca había
tenido y que mi madre muy
inteligentemente me dijo van a mira hija
procura
en una persona cabal no le hagas daño a
nadie no te hagas daño a ti misma pero
tú vive hija mía y me dio la total
libertad de ser pues eso lo que soy hoy
en día bueno pues nada empecé a salir
empecé a divertirme empecé a crear cosas
nuevas a hacer muchísimas cosas en
albacete y entre medias de esas clases
de teatro y todo eso voy a presentar a
un casting mis alumnos y mis alumnas de
teatro para televisión y el director de
televisión que había estado en esta
visión y que era un tío muy inteligente
de repente dice no quiero a los alumnos
quiero a la profesora gorda
es tremenda
eso fue un jueves viernes y el lunes
empecé en televisión
soy ha sido inconsciente con un contrato
que fue temporal pero que fue al final
estuve casi 11 años en televisión está
en televisión estado en radio y todo ahí
a partir de ahí empezó mi carrera
comunicadora no es que haya sido sabéis
sea no ha sido una cosa meteórica vale
pero si no lo que sí es verdad es que me
ayuda mucho a hablar a crecer ya darme
cuenta de que había dos cosas que me
encantaban desde pequeña aunque no
hablase una hacer feliz a través de la
risa que siempre he intentado ser amable
en mi forma de comunicar y la otra que
me encantaba decir la verdad comunicar y
ser justa y en parte eso es lo que hago
también hoy en día mis espectáculos no
me gusta hablar claro me gusta la
justicia y me gusta la realidad
he estado muchos años en comunicación
haciendo muchas cosas y estoy encantada
y he conocido a mucha gente y ha
aprendido mucho eso me ha ido
evolucionando después en el teatro
empecé a hacer muchas cosas empecé a
escribir guiones a dirigir a natal y al
final bueno pues de repente me di cuenta
de algo también muy curioso inventé una
especie de taller teatro que yo llevaba
por ahí que consistía en una cosa se
llamaba la pecera la pecera consiste en
una pecera de cristal yo entraba o
algunos azafatos o que fuese entraba ya
todo el mundo le daba una hoja y un boli
un lápiz y yo empezaba el espectáculo
siempre diciendo os voy a permitir que
me preguntáis lo que queréis preguntéis
lo que lo que os apetezca y os juro que
os voy a decir la verdad
quien hace eso hoy
quién contesta realmente la verdad
quien de verdad si le preguntas algo sea
personal y propio o sea a nivel general
te va a decir realmente lo que opina
complicado y cada día más en un mundo
donde cada día es más complicado ser
verdadero no porque estamos muy
acostumbrados a una cosa a estar siempre
felices
esto sí pero quién va a decir la verdad
de lo que te pregunten sorprendentemente
ese espectáculo dio paso a otro
increíble
que se llama master sex lo he llevado
dos años y me ha dado muchísimas
satisfacciones
muchas
master sex es un espectáculo donde yo
soy por supuesto la master hombre de
porque os voy a decir una cosa yo no
hablaba hasta la adolescencia pero luego
como podéis ver rajo muchísimo y además
pase de ser sumisa a ser dominado la
cuestión es que yo pasé de todo esto a
todo esto y en el másters es con que me
encontré fue fácil cogí las preguntas de
la pecera que por cierto el 80% de las
preguntas de la pecera eran sobre sexo
siempre preguntaban sobre sexo ya no
solamente el general también incluso de
mi sexo y de lo que yo hacía no cosas
que tal cogí eso cogí las mejores
preguntas y me elaboré un espectáculo
entero he llevado durante los años un
espectáculo en el cual hago un dual
explicó las 10 preguntas que las mujeres
se hacen mujeres y hombres se hacen
sobre hombres y explicó las preguntas
que los hombres se hacen sobre el sexo
de las mujeres y las mujeres también
sobre mujeres sorprendentemente es un
espectáculo donde precisamente la
premisa es hablar claro
y en este mundo en el que vivimos en un
día en el que ya os digo casi todo el
mundo parece que se ofende
yo nunca ha tenido problemas he estado
en pueblos con gente mayor estado en
institutos con gente joven que se piensa
que sabe mucho de sexo pero de lo que sí
saben es del porno por internet pero el
sexo no saben nada
he estado en muchísimos sitios con todo
tipo de personas bares restaurantes
teatros con poquita gente con muchísima
gente y lo bueno de ese espectáculo lo
bueno de explicar cosas y hablar claro
sobre el sexo es que cuando lo haces
desde la naturalidad y llamas a las
cosas por su nombre y lo explicas desde
la bondad
puedes hablar de todo
fijaros como empezado
os he contado que mi vida ha sido
terrible
pero no sé emocionado podría haberlo
hecho porque porque con el humor con la
naturalidad y con la forma de hablar
puedes modificar también el estado de la
gente y el estado de las personas que te
están escuchando yo os aconsejo cuando
vayáis a hablar en público y esto me
encanta cuando yo lo hago así para
conferencias y tal hay dos premisas que
tengo siempre una son dos eses
con mis curvas 12 61 sorprenderles y
otras dile a diles algo sexual
porque el sexo siempre fija
la gente está durmiendo hace calor se
está bancando dice quién es esta tía
gorda que está ahí arriba
dice que la conocemos la conocerá su
madre a la hora de comer las croquetas
no lo sé quién es ahora mismo no pero si
yo hago una mención al sexo
automáticamente veis
es así es así
ya este punto
que todavía me queda un poquito de
tiempo y estoy encantada quiero hacer un
ejercicio vale divertido un ejercicio
divertido necesito tres voluntarios
voluntarios o voluntarias que a mí a mí
me cabe todo
gracias fantástico ven y los 3
el primero que llegue va a hacer algo
maravilloso ha sido
hay que reposar en el círculo perdóname
puedes quitar esto
esto es un ejemplo de cómo hacer que los
que están durmiendo a las cuatro y pico
de la tarde la siesta los estoy viendo
bueno nos veo la verdad que también
romperlo
menos mal que no le he pedido que me
suelte el sujetador
vale quítame el kimono por favor
es que hay algo matthäus porque en que
venir
empezaba una charla
por favor me puede estar los dos
rotuladores
veréis cómo os acordaréis de mí el día
de mañana
los de cds también se están acordando de
mí bien este rotulador es para ti
pero que por salir más llama la atención
bien vamos a hacer un ejercicio nos
parece bien un ejercicio que sirve para
hablar claro y sirve para romper tabús y
que yo también hago mucho en teatro
veréis ya veréis puede romper tu kim
esfera te puedo tocar
con el calor que hace le voy a hacer una
cosa te voy a mirar unos segundos a los
ojos y te voy a permitir que escribas en
mi cuerpo la palabra que has pensado
mientras te miro por cierto en cualquier
parte de mi cuerpo que tú elijas
sea la que sea
estamos sin tabús y hablando claro
voy a ser bueno
soy toda tuya
elige zona
tú solamente has venido como un amante
mío de estos que me quitan el timón
emerja desnuda porque me encanta también
su papel es importante
que cualquier trozo quieres de este
pedazo de cuerpo serrano
lo veis
no me lo puedo creer o sea que tengo que
pasar uno por uno enseñaron las tetas
no pasa nada dilo tú di que pone aquí la
calor
y te das cuenta eso es lo que transmito
a él
ya de chica preciosa ven aquí qué guapa
nena qué caderas que maravilla ojalá
estuviese yo que yo no soy gorda que
ellos que soy serrana y soy de guasa
a ver qué va a pasar
valiente
qué te parece no sabe ni ná un aplauso
para ellos gracias
estoy más acostumbrada a que me desnude
en que a que me vista
es muy difícil ser comunicadora ser
artista y ser cómica cuando la gente te
prejuzga antes de conocerte en este caso
ellos ya tenían un poquito de
información y han opinado con el corazón
vale stella calloni claro porque es que
hace mucho calor aquí en la verdad y
ella muy valiente o valiente me va me
vale pero es complicado sabéis por qué
porque a lo largo de mi profesión en
contra lo que mucha gente pueda pensar
dentro del mundo del teatro no hay tanto
machismo en el mundo del cine que
también estoy en cine tampoco mucho pero
en el mundo del monólogo del cómico
ya es otro tema fijaros que está estado
en el punto de que a veces presentando
un benéfico porque yo tengo una premisa
que es muy de alejandro jodorowsky y es
que cuando alguien tiene un talento
tiene que cobrarlo pero tiene que
regalarlo yo lo cobra en mi trabajo pero
a mí cuando me llama a cualquier ong
cualquier benéfico cualquier persona que
me diste algo para algún familiar o eso
alguna gran onu ong yo regalo mis
presentaciones regalo mi humor regalo lo
que tenga que regalar mío creo que es
una forma de tener buen karma y de
regalar aquello que tú tienes por mucho
que te ha costado tener pero es una
forma de dar y de sacar fuera también lo
que has conseguido cuando a mí hay gente
que me dice bueno es que tú te mueves en
un mundo de monologuista es muy duro muy
machista si es cierto mirar una mujer no
es cómo se viste o como parece ser una
mujer es lo que lleva detrás y un hombre
también no se puede juzgar una persona
porque tú la veas así fuerte decidida
hablando claro tienes que tener en
cuenta lo que lleva detrás las
zapatillas que se puso las cicatrices
que tienen
las estrías que llevan las batallas y
las guerras que ha ganado ha perdido
todo solo tienes que tener en cuenta en
mi caso hace poco en un benefico por
ejemplo en un pueblo me presentaron yo
llevaba un vestido negro no como este
que llevo hoy sino absolutamente
cubierta manga larga y todo y el
presentador me presentó de la siguiente
forma bueno era con todos ustedes yo era
por cierto cierre de cartel había dos
chicos delante los presentó genial yo
era así de cartel porque la edad que más
años llevaba y cuando salí a presentarme
él dijo manera a todos con todos ustedes
charo romero una cómica que que puede
decir de ella pues que va vestida como
una [ __ ]
hoy he venido así para demostrar que se
puede hablar claro y que se puede venir
vestida como una quiera y que la gente
piense de ti que hace mucha calor y que
valiente a hablar claro